I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense and so at the time we didn't
know what we were going to start okay
and so then you start looking at the
assets you've got me I'm obsessed with
community I'm obsessed with filmmaking
yeah all that and you've got my partner
who is who the punchline will end up
being that he's really good at
operations and that becomes very
necessary in the business we decided to
start and then my other partner who was
just obsessed with nutrition I mean the
guy was obsessed and so we're at a
Technology I'd be that friend oh it was
awesome so he would come in and talk
about nutrition all the time and so we
were all like all the people that
complain that there's too much noise out
in the world of fitness and who do you
listed we were all just like we listened
to him yeah and so he was yoked ripped
whatever yeah we're like Fox you tell us
what to do we'll do it yeah and so he
would tell people most people wouldn't
do it but I actually would and I
followed through and it works completely
changed my physique added muscle got
lean like it was incredible and all that
time now we're like well what's our next
business we're like well the thing that
we talk about when we're in neutral
we're not trying to get rid of whatever
is always nutrition okay and so then I'm
like well what would be my hook into
that I love it personally but not enough
to show up and fight every day but my
mom and my sister are morbidly obese mmm
now that I can get behind I can show up
and fight for my family so then I just
started investing right taking my value
system and saying okay I'm gonna end
metabolic disease and I'm gonna help my
mom and my sister and there's a great
mother Theresa quote it says nobody will
I for the many but people will act for
the one so I'm like I'm just gonna show
them fight for those two I'm gonna think
about them it's easy to picture it's
easy to imagine I know I'm gonna lose
them too soon because they just they're
not making the right future yeah it's
gonna kill so if we can make food that
they choose based on taste and it
happens to be good for them then we've
got something and my other two partners
were doing it for very different reasons
maybe as much as they cared about my mom
and my sister they weren't showing up
every day and fighting for them nor
would I expect them to so we each had
our own reason to want to be there but
if you align selfish desires you can do
some pretty extraordinary things yeah
since I was in charge of marketing I
could just tell my story yeah like look
here was my own weight loss journey and
I come from this morbidly obese family
and I want to help them and I am NOT
stupid I know that they're on
of millions maybe a billion or more
people that struggle with food exactly
the way that they do and so that became
the the guiding light of the company in
metabolic disease
[Music]